yeah I don't think there's any question
about that you know personally I'm a big
fan of democracy and I think that all
the countries that have fully developed
you know all countries that have become
rich and become democracies but we see
quite a few different patterns around
the world the other countries that like
chill a that developed under
authoritarianism for several decades and
then became Democratic South Korea is
another example of a country that
developed pretty far under
authoritarianism and then became
Democratic so I think the historical
evidence is that China can certainly
grow for another decade or longer
without significant political change